[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER L.
EISGRUBER: By honoring
Toni Morrison in this way, we
recognize the indelible impact
she has had on this university.
Arriving at Princeton in 1989 as
the Robert F. Goheen Professor
in the Humanities, Morrison's
transformative presence
as a member of the
creative writing program
played a central role in
diversifying our campus
by attracting other faculty and
students of color to Princeton
and deepening our commitment
to African American studies.
She also served as a
catalyst for expanding
Princeton's commitment to the
creative and performing arts.
In 1994, she founded
the Princeton Atelier.
Professor Morrison's
leadership has
helped Princeton to
become the increasingly
imaginative and inclusive
institution that we know today.
Through these myriad
contributions, and now
through the name
of Morrison Hall,
Professor Morrison's legacy
will have enduring significance
for all who walk our campus.
RUTH SIMMONS: West College
is an iconic structure,
part of the fabric of
the Princeton identity.
How right and just for
Morrison to be indelibly linked
with its history.
Her presence in a new
Princeton narrative
is not so much to endorse the
way things have always been,
but to point to the way they
can and will be in the future.
The bookends of that
powerful display
of her artistry on a snowy
night, on the one hand,
and the dedication of
Morrison Hall on the other,
celebrate the compelling
story of her association
with this university.
Forever to be entwined the
story of a great writer
and a great university
with the good sense
to turn towards
the future will be
recounted through the ages
advancing the legacy of both
in a powerful way.
MACKENZIE BEZOS: In that first
workshop with her a year later
when she shut the
classroom door and treated
us like we were the only
people in the world.
Sharing excerpts from
books that she loved.
And telling stories that
made her laugh until tears
streamed from her eyes.
And focusing the group's
attention on each student's
writing with her keen
observations and solemn
attention.
Or when senior
year I sat waiting
in that crowded anteroom once
a month for my thesis meeting.
And discovered that when
her advisees' turns come,
she would draw them out
of that waiting area.
And shut the door on
the ringing phones.
And give them two
impossibly focused hours.
Turning the pages of their
manuscripts one by one.
And initiating painstaking
and patient conversations
about individual words, and
phrases, and the stories they
were struggling to create.
I would say that one of the most
inspiring and surprising things
that she has given
me is a real example
of a life of passionate devotion
to more than one calling.
TONI MORRISON: This is
a very, very special,
beautiful occasion for me.
Thank you, thank you both.
You're very, very
important to me.
I'm so happy that you
were willing to come
to tell me how wonderful I was.
[APPLAUSE]